[موسيقى]
عيد الميلاد في الفاتيكان لا يكتمل
بدون مشهد المهد ، وهو تقليد إيطالي
يعود إلى القديس
فرنسيس ، ويوجد 100 منهم في جميع
أنحاء الفاتيكان بما في ذلك هنا في
كنيسة سيستين ، قضى جوزيبي ممر
وزوجته مع اثنين من أصدقائه
تسعة أشهر من العمل الشاق لإنشاء هذا
المشهد المستوحى من نابولي مع التأكد من
أن الألوان والأقمشة تكمل
اللوحات الجدارية الشهيرة لمايكل أنجلو
في ساحة القديس بطرس استخدم الحرفيون من
منطقة البندقية
أرز مصدر مستدام من الأشجار التي
سقطت بالفعل لنحت
التماثيل بكل صخب
وصخب وتسويق  يقول البابا فرانسيس في عيد
الميلاد إن مغارة الميلاد هي
العلامة المرئية لما يدور هذا الموسم
حقًا عن
المقلاة والأصفر. يشرح الكاهن
الفرنسيسكاني المسؤول عن كاتدرائية القديس بطرس
تناقض الإيمان المسيحي
في عيد الميلاد
من أجل الاقتراب من الرجال
والنساء  يجعل من نفسه رضيعًا أكثر
الأشياء هشاشة في العالم
كل ن  مشهد النشاط هو تعبير
عن الأشخاص الذين جعلوه يقول مثل
هذا المشهد الأوكراني ، إنه جميل جدًا لدرجة أن
هناك العديد من مشاهد يوميات DVD
مشاهد يابانية هندية أفريقية تمثل كل واحدة
معنى
راهب المهد والأصفر يقول
مشهد المهد الحقيقي في  ما يهم قلب كل شخص
هو أنه مفتوح
ومستعد للترحيب بأمل الموسم